yo talk to me about the UCLA days man
because uh one of my best friends uh is
a UCLA Bruin and he was in college in a
fraternity when you were playing and he
was just like
so excited when I told him that you were
going to be on the show uh what was like
the energy being because an LA kid at
UCLA obviously UCLA was crazy yo you
guys were were really good yeah we we
had once again some problems my freshman
year Shake cotton they didn't let in he
was supposed to come with us uh and then
Jelani and Chris they got caught up you
know for smoking during uh like the
first year or whatnot
um and so we kind of played like
everybody played out of position my
freshman year we started two point
guards Toby Paley played like three
Chris Johnson played the 4jr Henderson
played the five and so
um it was crazy because we had all the
talent if our if our team would have
potentially came together you know what
I mean and we could have sustained it we
had all the talent to go out and win it
so UCLA it's all about winning national
championships for sure so for me it was
just like man like I want to win a
National Championship but I also want to
like like this [__] on fire you know
what I mean like let's send it up you
know and so you know
crosses dunks all that like we were
there to like no matter what we gonna
we're gonna create some entertainment
you know what I mean growing up watching
UCLA basketball it was always like they
were always good always highlights so I
was like man I gotta go there and like I
gotta make sure I get my highlights
right you know what I mean like they
remember me yeah it was more so like
they have to remember me like I can't
just be you know a traditional point
guard that got good stats and make all
conference no I gotta do some [__] where
these people are gonna remember me you
know what I mean do you feel like USC is
slowly taking over La absolutely no I
gotta ask yeah because they got they got
they got bronnie James and then Rodman
if you don't knock it off they're
definitely taking over I mean they've
kind of had football yeah they ain't
even got football we beat them listen
the the link Lincoln Riley's a hell of a
coach yeah man yeah it's a famous quote
just SC
it's just SC don't worry about it it's
so crazy too because those two colleges
like if for people who don't know like
if you were to just drive around USC
it's in South Central right and then if
you go to the other side of town it's
It's UCLA it's like night and day The
Vibes of the campuses yeah just the
students like the student flavor and
energy is different
you know like uh SC got like more of a
downtown like they more like downtown so
they got like a a New York kind of vibe
right you know what I mean or like a I
don't know a downtown Vibe on the West
Side people chilling super laying out
you know we're going to the beach you
know people from SC they're not driving
all the way to the you know what I mean
they're not driving all the way to the
beach they're going to go trying to find
a rooftop Pooler